i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa cinco años después
del asesinato de 11 miembros de su
redacción y otras 6 personas en una
serie de atentados en parís que
conmovieron al mundo el semanario
satírico charlie hebdo vuelve a ser
noticia para marcar el inicio del juicio
contra 14 personas acusadas de
complicidad con los tres atacantes que
murieron a manos de la policía
la revista volvió a publicar las
controvertidas caricaturas del profeta
mahoma por las que los asesinos
intentaron justificar sus actos
terroristas empezamos el juicio contra
los presuntos cómplices de los atentados
empezó con decenas de familiares de las
víctimas siguiéndolo el proceso será
filmado por primera vez para la historia
al publicar de nuevo las caricaturas de
mahoma charlie hebdo reabre el debate
sobre lo que permite el derecho
fundamental a la libertad de expresión
frente a lo que algunas culturas o
religiones pueden considerar blasfemia
se trata de los dibujos de mahoma que
fueron publicados origina
en el diario danés jyllands posten en
2005 en uno de ellos se puede ver al
profeta caracterizado con un turbante en
forma de bomba esto generó violentas
protestas por parte de los musulmanes en
una muestra de solidaridad charlando
reeditó las caricaturas en 2006 e
incluyó una propia ahora todas fueron
recopiladas para una edición especial la
revista explicó que la republicación de
los dibujos es necesaria para que los
jóvenes entiendan el juicio ya que han
pasado 14 años desde su primera
publicación añade que son documentos con
un valor histórico y penal
nos han pedido a menudo que hagamos
otras caricaturas de mahoma siempre lo
habíamos rechazado no porque esté
prohibido la ley nos autoriza sino
porque se necesitaba una buena razón
para hacerlo una razón que tenga sentido
y que aporte algo al debate para muchos
publicar estas caricaturas es parte
integral de la libertad de expresión
países occidentales y de otras latitudes
garantizan en sus legislaciones este
derecho universal sin embargo en otras
culturas como el islam ciertas
manifestaciones son consideradas tabú en
la religión este es uno de los temas más
sensibles para el islam caricaturizar a
un personaje ya sea de manera satírica o
respetuosa está prohibido a diferencia
del catolicismo los musulmanes no
permiten estatuas o imágenes de ala o
mahoma a su juicio esto fomenta la
idolatría ya que no habría una conexión
directa con dios sino con una
representación eso constituye para los
musulmanes una clase
lo que sentimos mucho es que este tema
de la libertad de expresión se utiliza
mucho en este momento para simplemente
justificar se puede ofender a los
musulmanes no hay ningún problema se
puede ofender a los musulmanes porque
hay libertad de expresión ahora ese
mismo principio no se invoca con
respecto a otras cosas que sí ofender a
las personas y se ofenden a las personas
entonces ya aquí no hay libertad de
expresión de acuerdo con reporteros sin
fronteras en 69 naciones del mundo la
blasfemia sigue siendo un delito y en
seis de ellos se castiga hasta con la
pena de muerte tras la revolución
francesa francia fue el primer país del
mundo en despenalizar la igual han hecho
muchas otras naciones que consideran la
libertad de blasfemar parte integral de
la libertad de expresión y en estados
que se enorgullecen de su laicidad como
francia esa libertad incluye criticar y
caricaturizar el poder religioso entre
otros el mismo presidente francés
emmanuel macrón defendió este derecho
recientemente
también hay en francia una libertad para
blasfemar que está unida a la libertad
de conciencia y así desde donde estoy
estoy aquí para proteger todas estas
libertades la propuesta de libertad
para conocer la opinión entre la
comunidad charlie hebdo también encargó
una encuesta a la empresa ifop en total
fueron consultados 1500 ciudadanos
franceses 500 de ellos musulmanes la
empresa dice que en unos 15 años la
opinión de los franceses sobre el
derecho a caricaturizar figuras
religiosas ha evolucionado por ejemplo
el 59 por ciento de los no musulmanes
aprobaron la publicación de este tipo de
caricaturas en nombre de la libertad de
expresión
a diferencia del 38 por ciento que se
registró en 2006 sin embargo un 69 por
ciento de los musulmanes dice que
charlie hebdo se equivocó con este tipo
de publicación aunque un 72 por ciento
condena firmemente los atentados entre
los franceses no musulmanes
la condena es aún mayor 88 por ciento
pero un 26 por ciento de los musulmanes
menores de 25 años no condenan
explícitamente a los autores del
atentado el 59 por ciento de los
musulmanes dijo que participaría en un
minuto de silencio en homenaje a las
víctimas del atentado de charly eto'o y
lo mismo opinó el 80% de los
no musulmanes
los medios de comunicación franceses por
supuesto han estado siguiendo la
discusión el periódico lemons y todas
las palabras del director de charlie
hebdo quien a través de la nueva
publicación de la revista dijo nunca nos
rendiremos y agrega el odio que nos
golpeó sigue ahí y desde 2015 se ha
tomado el tiempo de transformarse de
cambiar su apariencia para pasar
desapercibido y continuar tranquilamente
su cruzada despiadada una columna del
diario le figaro titula lo siguiente
proceso de los atentados de 2015 hoy el
espíritu charly está puesto en cuestión
más que nunca refiriéndose a la
manifestación de 2015 llamada jesuit
charly en la que millones de personas
expresaron su solidaridad con charly
yendo
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www punto frente 4
punto com
[Música]